wohl eines der größten rätsel der physik
oder das verrät allein schon ihr name
denn einzig omg also oh my god hatten
sich die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler 1991 einfallen lassen
als sie diese teilchen entdeckt hatten
ihr ursprungsort blieb bis jetzt ein
großes rätsel
doch jetzt ist klar die strahlung stammt
aus fernen galaxien und ihre energie ist
so unfassbar und erschreckend hoch
milliardenfach so schnell wie andere
gewöhnliche teilchen aus dem all ihr
habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zu diesem kuriosen
teilchen welche fundamentalen
erkenntnisse verraten sie über den
ursprung des universums und können sie
uns gefährlich werden jetzt den klicks
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
ja also wir sind hier übrigens bei how
to music und das ist neues musikformat
dass ich produziere tut mir einen
gefallen abonniert unbedingt diesen
kanal es wird sensationell wir begleiten
sechs musikerinnen und musiker auf dem
weg zu ihrer karriere ja wir haben ja
öfter schon hier darüber berichtet
unentwegt erreicht kosmische strahlung
die atmosphäre konkret handelt es sich
um schneller an tobt gerne verschiedener
chemischer elemente vor allem die sonne
sendet kosmische teilchen den
sogenannten sonnen wenn sie erreichen
energien um die 100 millionen
elektronenvolt das kann auf der erde zu
störungen führen beispielsweise in der
stromversorgung und im funkverkehr doch
die sogenannten oh my god teilchen
übertreffen wirklich alles von solch
einem teilchen getroffen zu werden würde
sich wohl anfühlen wie von einem richtig
hart geschlagenen baseball
doch dazu kommt es sicher nicht denn a
sind die teilchen eher selten und b
werden sie durch die atmosphäre in ihrer
unfassbaren energie abgebremst doch erst
jetzt konnte aus ein team aus mehr als
40 forscherinnen und forschern aus 18
ländern ihre konkreten ursprung
nachweisen
die teilchen gelangen demnach von
entfernten außer galaktischen objekten
zur erde jenseits unserer milchstraße
das zeigt die analyse der messdaten die
von dem argentinischen per order
observatorium stammen zitat diese neuen
erkenntnisse werden es uns ermöglichen
fundamentale fragen über die entstehung
des universums der milchstraße und
anderen galaxien zu klären das sagt der
beteiligte astrophysiker karl heinz
kemper den gemessenen rekord hält an
teilchen mit rund 303
millionen elektronenvolt dieselbe
energie also die ein schnell geschlagen
oder tennis oder baseball hat
omg also wahrsten sinne des wortes das
argentinische auf story und besteht aus
unvorstellbaren 1600 detektoren die auf
einer fläche von 3.000 quadratkilometern
verteilt sind das ist größer als das
bundesland saarland es gibt 1600
messstationen jeweils einen detektor und
zwölf tonnen wasser fassen
das wasser dient tatsächlich der
energiemessung dabei macht sich das
forschungsteam zunutze dass die teilchen
der kosmischen strahlung mit
luftmolekülen zusammen prasseln diese
werden zerschmetterte ihre bruchstücke
kollidieren weiter es entsteht eine
lawine aus zeichen und die energie der
ursprünglichen teilchen teilt sich auf
treffen diese sehr energiereichen
teilchen auf das wasser in den tanks
bewegen sie sich dort schneller als das
licht normalerweise im wasser dazu
kampert das kann man sich ähnlich
vorstellen über ein flugzeug das die
schallmauer dürfte zudem wenden sie
licht aus die so genannte sprengkopf
strahlung die kann dann durch die
detektoren nachgewiesen werden die
ankunftszeit der teilchen lawine an den
verschiedenen messstationen hilft dem
forschungsteam zu bestimmen
aus welcher richtung sie gekommen sind
und zwar bis zu einem grad genau
dennoch ist es kaum möglich die exakte
quelle zu bestimmen denn ihr wisst im
all existieren unzählige kosmische
magnetfelder durch die die teilchen
abgelenkt werden nur wenn die teilchen
höhere energien haben kommen sie nicht
ab vom kurs doch wie schon gesagt omg
teilchen mit derart hohen energien
kommen nur selten auf der erde an
schätzungen zufolge fällt pro jahr 100
solcher teilchen auf die fläche eines
fußballfeldes doch die fläche des
observatoriums groß genug um viele hoher
energetischer teilchen zu analysieren
für die aktuelle studie wurden die
messdaten von zehn jahren berücksichtigt
jetzt steht noch ein feinschliff an
denn bisher werden alle kosmischen
teilchen berücksichtigt doch da sie
unterschiedlich schwere atomkern haben
fliegen verschiedene teilchen extrem
unterschiedlich reisen beispielsweise
weniger geradlinig als helium kerne wenn
demnächst also die schweren atomkerne
herausgefiltert werden könnte dies ein
schärferes bild der genauen quellen
liefert wenn er als erstes dazu also zum
thema der um die teilchen und zu allen
an
thema erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer bei whatsapp hier ist der
link dazu dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion vom klick zum
mitmachen und tut mir den gefallen ist
wird wirklich ein hammer projekt hier
auto music in berlin sechs
nachwuchsmusikerinnen und musiker auf
dem weg zum erfolg die begleiten mehr
und das wird wirklich spannend ja und
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen dafür das
abo nicht vergessen und die glocke genau
die müsste unbedingt leuten und hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken neues teilchen entdeckt
ansonsten bis dann bleibt da